et bien le notre petit village dispose
d'une petite salle des fêtes que qu'on
loue
occasionnellement et samedi soir donc
elle était louée à un groupe de jeunes
extérieur que je ne connaissais pas quoi
c'est pas du village d'accord non non du
tout
c'est pas moi qui m'en occupe j'ai un
conseiller qui qui est délégué pour pour
gérer la salle et je fais complètement
confiance et
déjà à partir de 22h
voilà le tapage nocturne commencé les
rivens commencer à se plaindre auprès de
moi mais alors parce qu'ils avaient loué
la salle c'est pourquoi pour faire une
soirée ouais c'est un anniversaire
forcément vous savez quel avoir du bruit
quand même c'est sûr mais là c'était
beaucoup vraiment c'était énorme ils
étaient une trentaine une trentaine non
mais après l'anniversaire
c'est normal mais là c'était vraiment
beaucoup et ça choque notre salle elle
est en plein milieu du village voilà il
fallait vraiment réduire un petit peu il
y a un juste compromis
donc il y avait une
un bon compromis quoi voilà pour trouver
ce qui acceptable et vous avez
c'est dans la nuit vers 2h30 du matin
vous rendez dans la salle de bain et 22h
22h on leur a demandé de baisser un peu
et après ça c'est plutôt bien passé
après moi j'habite du sans face donc je
suis un peu aux premières loges on
surveiller parce que quand on est maire
d'une petite commune comme la nôtre on
fait tout on est en première ligne pour
première le problème exactement
et c'est plutôt voilà à 2h30 du matin il
y a une bagarre générale qui a éclaté
dans la rue quoi mais avec qui entre
entre
avec des autres du tout du tout mais
c'était très violent et donc moi
habitant en face j'ai décidé
d'appeler la gendarmerie sur parce que
là une gendarmerie de la gendarmerie
vient d'où de Nancy non c'est
gerbévilliers ou Lunéville voilà une
dizaine de kilomètres
faut quand même un quart d'heure 20
minutes et
mais en attendant que les gendarmes
arrivent accompagnés d'un de mes amis je
suis allé notifié au locataire de la
salle qui était pour moi le référent que
on allait mettre un terme à leur fête et
qu'il fallait qu'il range toutes les
gens sortent parce que là ça partait un
peu dans tous les sens et la sasulation
a commencé à être ingérable donc ça
c'est à 2h30 du matin donc la bagarre
donc je suis rentré je suis vraiment à
l'entrée de la salle et ça a pas plu à
certains si vous en dit
ils m'ont rien dit c'est là que j'ai
pris un coup direct
je suis arrivé en présentant comme étant
le maire j'ai dit quoi donc là il y a la
musique et tout vous étiez s'il vous
plaît je suis le maire du village voilà
il y avait déjà plus beaucoup de musique
là parce qu'ils étaient plutôt occupé à
se battre d'accord et donc là ouais ils
étaient en majorité fortement alcoolisé
on peut le préciser aussi et là j'ai
pris une claque
dans la joue là c'est même pas quoi
c'est même pas d'où ça venait si après
j'ai pu identifier mais avec une
stupéfaction totale je m'attendais pas
du tout à ça j'étais allé vraiment en
mode décontracte
ouais en shortong enfin voilà il faisait
chaud hein et
là je me suis dit waouh ça tourne ça va
mal tourner pour moi quoi donc là vous
prenez j'ai décidé avec mon ami que de
repartir me réfugier chez moi là déjà
vous prenez une feuille vous prenez une
gifle il commençait tout ça s'énerver
juste une gifle
je suis reparti sauf que en partant dans
le couloir et il y a un groupe qui m'a
suivi
et donc les mecs est arrivé dehors ils
ont commencé à me courir après dans la
rue quoi donc moi j'ai couru aussi
on va je vais pas vite on tourne vite
ils m'ont vite rattrapé et
pour me mettre au sol non ouais vous
étiez tout seul il était plus là votre
fille mais ils étaient aussi avaient
appris
ils étaient Wayne environ donc là il
vous attrape et là ils mettent au sol et
là je me suis enfin j'étais déjà effrayé
quand il courait après quoi ça va très
vite c'est une trentaine de secondes et
là au sol j'ai pris plein de coups je me
suis mis en boule en protection et
mon ami qui est assez imposant Stéphane
je le remercie encore lui s'est dégagé
assez vite
et il est venu pour pour les faire fuir
et moi de mon côté en même temps j'ai un
peu fait le mort sur la route quoi a pu
bouger j'ai même entendu un qui disait
il est mort il est mort et ça il a
peut-être effrayé et à ce moment-là ils
ont arrêté et mais j'ai eu la peur de ma
vie c'est normal j'ai vraiment cru que
j'allais mourir et j'en suis encore
choqué quoi c'est normal ensuite ils
sont volatilisés assez vite
et elle a la gendarmerie est intervenue
quoi mais c'est toujours un choc pour
moi ils ont été interpellé c'est en
cours
qu'est-ce qui risque là parce que comme
d'habitude on se dit voilà ils ont tapé
mais voilà et on va dire qu'ils étaient
sous l'emprise de l'alcool et ils ont
peut-être c'est peut-être des mineurs
donc ils vont ressortir dans deux jours
et comme d'habitude et vous vous dites
quoi parce que vous êtes de l'autre côté
mine de rien vous êtes quand même
de la République c'est pour ça c'est ça
qui est important parce que
je vous le dis on sait très bien et vous
ressortir dans deux jours
donc vous vous avez vous avez de choqué
toute votre vie choqué ouais à un moment
déjà il y aura un avant et un après non
mais c'est important complètement je
pensais pas je pensais que nous à une
petite commune rurale on était à l'abri
de tout ça bien sûr passer plutôt en
ville je me trompais en fait on est le
contre-exemple samedi soir et ouais
c'est vrai que je vais je vais ça
longtemps dans ma tête vous rendez
compte ou pas ils ont été identifiés on
a identifié les gars une partie il y a
combien de mecs qui ont été identifiés
pour l'instant qui vous ont porté des
coups il y a une partie ils sont entre 7
8 il y a 7 gars c'est sûr et vous
emportez des coups cette mecs il y en a
deux interpellent pour le moment voilà
16 18
jours ils sont même pas non ils vont
rester même pas voilà ils vont rester
deux heures ou 3h et puis ils vont être
entendu et puis ils vont être relâchés
c'est ça mais vous dites quoi vous parce
que ça j'aimerais bien savoir avoir la
vie d'un élu de la République sur ce qui
se passe actuellement où là voilà pour
le coup vous êtes vous avez été de
l'autre côté c'est à dire que vous avez
été agressé par des jeunes nous on a des
histoires comme ça tous les jours aussi
qui sont de du même acabit vous êtes
venu mourir ouais complètement vous
rendez compte j'ai eu des fractions de
seconde ils avaient une telle
détermination et vous disiez quoi quand
il vous tapez il parlait pas
assez bêtement parce qu'ils étaient ivre
morts je sais pas il savait que j'étais
le maire et ce qui tabassait le maire ou
est-ce qu'il tabassait l'homme ça je
peux pas vous dire voilà ok
on a une fonction nous-mère de petites
communes ce qui est vraiment pas
évidente
au quotidien on est toujours en première
ligne pour résoudre les problèmes bien
souvent on évite à la gendarmerie
d'intervenir pour des problèmes de
voisinage ou autre et on a une grosse
partie de notre travail qui est bénévole
c'est pas ma profession je suis
agriculteur sur le village et donc j'y
suis présent aussi puisque je travaille
sur le village vous êtes vous êtes marié
oui vous avez dit quoi votre femme que
vous êtes rentré ma femme il a fallu que
je la réveille pour lui dire qu'elle
vienne me chercher aux urgences 5h30 et
je vous jure que voilà ça a été un choc
aussi pour elle voilà et vous avez dans
un état ouais
ça a été compliqué au début vous avez
des enfants oui j'ai une fille quel âge
elle a 10 ans
la carte ce soir je vous fais des gros
bisous elle s'appelle comment capucine
capucine bon papa va mieux mais c'est
vrai que je vous dis moi je suis révolté
moi par ce qui se passe et aujourd'hui
vous vous dites quoi sur la justice vous
aimeriez qu'il se passe quoi pour eux
parce que j'ai envie de savoir ce que
veut dire un élu si vous êtes agréable
pour l'instant je ressens pas de colère
vraiment et non je suis sous le choc
encore je ressens pas de colère et voilà
je voudrais qu'on trouve des solutions
pour que ça se reproduise plus et le
problème c'est quoi c'est qu'il y a un
total de respect la solution pour cette
reproduit plus c'est une solution qui
passe par la justice aussi si les mecs
ils se disent de toute façon on peut
taper un maire on peut nous nous on a
moi j'ai un j'ai insulté un député j'ai
pris 3 millions et demi d'euros d'amende
eux ils vont prendre combien d'amandes
pour avoir taper un maire non mais c'est
plus grave non mais c'est quoi vous dire
donc aujourd'hui l'arcom est plus sévère
que la justice non mais c'est ça le
régulateur de l'audiovisuel est plus
sévère que la justice donc je vais vous
dire insulte un député c'est 12000 euros
d'amende au maximum et tu vous les avez
pratiquement jamais
agression sur une personne représentante
de l'État donc
la force publique
je pense que c'est pas 3 millions et
demi d'eau donc vous rendez compte
qu'aujourd'hui la justice est
100 fois plus clémente que un régulateur
de l'audiovisuel par exemple d'argent
c'est toutes les semaines que des mères
comme moi vous savez quoi moi j'ai parlé
mal dan Hidalgo à l'antenne on a pris
300000 euros d'amende bon écoute vous
vous avez vous êtes un maire autant
cannidalgo je vous le dis moi il y a pas
de voilà ni d'algo vous êtes autant mer
qu'anidalgo vous avez été passé à tabac
ils vont rester donc deux heures en
commissariat et ils vont partir oui mais
non mais non
quelqu'un qui a l'argent qui est dans un
groupe qui a l'argent c'est facile de
donner 300000 non non non il faut une
sanctions
parce que son histoire moi ce que je
retiens il est sorti de chez lui parce
qu'il entend du bruit à deux heures du
matin il il prend une claque il s'en va
ça veut dire les gens qu'est-ce qu'ils
disent moi je vais plus sortir aider mon
prochain pourquoi pourquoi dans les dans
les transports les gens ils veulent plus
bouger parce que
on est sur le témoignage de Monsieur le
Maire aujourd'hui vous vous allez vous
allez porter plainte ou pas j'ai déjà
porté plainte d'accord et naturellement
oui contre d'accord ouais ouais vous
voulez quand même une sanction c'est
normal lui voilà c'est normal qui votre
femme elle doit être plus énervée que
vous je suis sûr peut-être entre moi je
suis sûr non mais c'est certain contact
avec vous là où les parents de ses
agresseurs qui sont mineurs
non non est-ce que ça vous dévoile dans
votre mission de mer pour revenir là
comment vous voyez la mer non je sais
pas ça qui me démotive au contraire ça
aurait été des jeunes du village oui
peut-être mais là j'ai des questions ils
ont dit quoi les jeunes du village
bah j'ai un soutien total de la part
vraiment c'est agréable soutien même
juste de la population de j'espère que
vous allez vous remettre surtout est-ce
que vous avez retrouvé vos tongs
[Rires]
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
vous êtes formidable merci beaucoup